le mercredi 26 janvier de 17h30 à 20h30
la commune de montigny le bretonneux
organise une nouvelle édition de sa
soirée des métiers et de l'orientation
elle se déroulera à l'hôtel de ville
organisée par le pôle jeunesse la soirée
est ouverte à tous les aînés montant de
la 4e aux étudiants et jeunes diplômés
les destinataires de cet événement soit
évidemment les jeunes de 13 à 25 ans
mais aussi leurs parents qui les
accompagnent qui ont aussi souvent
beaucoup de questions objectif informer
sur l'orientation la réorientation les
métiers l'apprentissage ou encore le
service civique avec des stands
d'information des conférences des
témoignages des temps des changes impôts
le projet d'orientation projet de
professionnels voilà avec des
informations individuels avec des
professionnels de l'orientation il faut
parler alternance
découverte des métiers formations dans
le cadre d'un projet en particulier il
ya un deuxième pôle qui est le pôle
découverte des métiers
et surtout donc des métiers bien sûr
mais aussi des outils qui permettent de
clarifier un petit peu cette question là
de trouver des familles des familles de
métiers en fonction des goûts des
aptitudes des affinités du profil il ya
un troisième pôle qui est celui de la
mobilité en europe et du volontariat
voilà on abordera la question du service
civique
du service national universel voilà
entre autres il y aura un pôle
information en accès libre avec des
expositions qui vont aborder la question
à clarifier deux parcours sup de
l'orientation après la troisième du post
bac en bonus un escape game spécial
orientations sur le thème de star wars
sera prévu accès libre sous réserve de
présentation d'un pass sanitaire valide